[Music]
before we start this video
i just wanted to mention that only 21.6
percent of you
are subscribed so if you enjoy the
content please consider subscribing
to support the channel hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter
theory in today's video we're going to
be tackling a topic
which i'm sure will be subject to much
debate
who is the most powerful weasley more
importantly
how do each of the weasleys stack up
against each other
if we were to rank the famous wizarding
family by power
who would come out on top who would fall
to the bottom
i've made lots of ranking videos in the
past ranking the most powerful
slytherins hufflepuffs
ravenclaws gryffindors order of the
phoenix members
dumbledore's army members marauders
professors
and more if this is your cup of tea then
you may want to check out those videos
as well
however time and time again i've seen
this idea commented
so today let's look at the weasleys
there are nine
immediate family members of the weasleys
to which were introduced in the series
in no particular order ron charlie ginny
molly fred george percy arthur and bill
before we get into this i want you to
comment down below your own
rankings then watch the video and see
how they compare
the weasleys first make their mark right
near the beginning of the philosopher's
stone
when harry stumbles into them at
platform nine and three quarters
almost immediately we get the sense that
harry is going to be close with these
solid
kind people and over the course of the
books films
harry basically becomes family where
harry was chanted at the dursley
residence
which is ironic since he is actually
related to them he was conversely
welcomed with open arms at the weasley
residence
he was harry and through all their
quirks we love the wheezies
they are good people with nothing but
harry's best interest in mind
allowing him to spend countless holidays
at their home and always looking out for
him
but here's the thing about the weasleys
beneath their welcoming
warm exteriors they are all extremely
magically
talented a bit of history the weasleys
are members of the sacred 28
one of 28 wizarding families that were
thought
to still be truly pure blood by the time
the 1930s rolled around
however in spite of their pure blood
status the weasleys did not discriminate
against others
like many pureblood families did in fact
the weasleys recognized everyone as
their equals
muggles muggle-borns and half-bloods
alike for this reason
they were labeled as blood traitors
their lineage is long
and traceable and over the years there
have been many other powerful weasleys
but for now let's look at the ones we
know one thing to bear in mind is that
no weasley is weak
they are all powerful some are just more
powerful than others
this was the hardest power ranking list
that i've had to make so far
number nine percy weasley first things
first
percy is certainly the least popular of
the weasleys
i think that goes without saying he was
born in 1976
and was arthur and molly's third child
after bill and charlie
and though he personified many of the
positive weasley values
his mind did end up getting a bit
corrupted and he went down a
questionable path
he did however eventually redeem himself
he was a very ambitious person
but this also meant that he was a
stickler for the rules he was extremely
disapproving of fred and george's
constant pranks and tricks
and had convinced himself that in order
to get far in life you needed
structure his structured life calculated
demeanor
and strong desire to appease meant that
he eventually landed himself the roles
of prefect
head boy taking on additional
responsibilities while still a student
at hogwarts however just because percy
was ambitious
this ambition didn't necessarily
manifest itself in a form of a longing
for greater magical ability percy was a
good student
he attended classes got good grades and
did everything that was expected of him
but he didn't necessarily go above and
beyond magically
he never wanted to be powerful in the
sense that he could create all kinds of
powerful spells
he wanted to be like fudge he wanted to
be minister for magic
he wanted political power for this
reason
percy is at the bottom of the list
however don't get me wrong
percy is still a talented wizard number
eight
ron weasley first things first ron
definitely didn't start his life off
with immense magical power he had innate
ability
but it was largely untapped and it was
only over the course of the book's films
that we saw ron really start to build
confidence
and grow into his magical ability by the
end of the deathly hallows ron had faced
so much adversity with harry and
hermione
that he had more real-life experience
than 99.99
of wizards his age and this gave him the
jump start he needed
in the earlier books films his
incompetence is highlighted
however one thing that ron always had
was heart
and certainly courage this ultimately
meant that ron was destined to achieve
greater levels of power however if he
never had to undergo the trials and
tribulations that he did
then he may have never been the powerful
wizard that he is today
number seven arthur weasley arthur was
possibly the hardest name to place on
this list
largely because he's the weasley parent
and an accomplished wizard in his own
right
however i'm of the impression that many
of his children
ended up passing him in raw magical
power born in the year 1950
arthur was an active member of the order
of the phoenix ministry of magic
employee and dedicated father
he worked hard to support his family
financially but never failed to dedicate
time and love to them
however underneath arthur's soft side he
did have a bit of an edge
a part of him that was revealed whenever
his family was in danger
this edge is what i feel ultimately
contributes to his level of power
as over the course of his life arthur
has on numerous occasions
fought off death eaters he was a skilled
jewelist
transfiguration expert known to be able
to perform conjuration
and charms expert arthur weasley is
definitely
no joke number six ginny weasley
ginny aka jenevra weasley is a bit
unassuming when it comes to power
she is the youngest member of the
weasley family and arthur molly's only
daughter
however despite her small stature and
occasionally shy demeanor
particularly around harry ginny is an
exceptionally talented witch
this is even referenced in the books
yeah size is no guarantee of power
look at ginny like ron jenny's skills
develop as the series progresses
and by the time the film's come to an
end she is extremely talented
able to hold her own even against
powerful death eaters when dumbledore's
army was first founded
she quickly learned how to produce a
patronus charm and in no time at all was
adept at producing other powerful spells
like producto
being the only girl and the youngest in
a family full of older brothers
ginny had to develop thick skin and i
believe that this is largely what
contributed to the development of her
skills
number five and four fred and george
weasley
i'm grouping fred and george together
because well
they're almost meant to be grouped
together however what you might be
wondering now is
why they have separate rankings should
they be equal
well here's the thing yes they are
mostly equal
but george did end up living longer than
fred which means that
however marginally he likely honed his
skills a little bit more
i hope that logic makes sense for this
reason fred is number five and george is
number four
the powerful weasley twins were born in
the year 1978
and were sorted into gryffindor house
just a few years before ron
harry and hermione the boys were funny
well liked among the student body
and much to the dismay of the teachers
that were bemused by their antics
very good students however despite the
fun-loving demeanor
the twins were actually extremely
magically talented
from a very young age the boys were able
to produce advanced potions and spells
that were well above their pay grade in
terms of magical ability
here's the other thing that they had
going for them there were two of them
this meant that if fred learned a new
spell it wasn't long before george
learned it as well
and vice versa having someone so close
to you to bounce ideas off of
is almost always going to contribute to
a better understanding of something
and in the case of the weasley twins
this particularly contributed to their
ability to produce potions
not only that the twins were able to
hold their own in nearly any
circumstance
they were truly well-rounded well-liked
individuals the fact that the two boys
were able to achieve
so much at such a young age tells me
that their innate ability is comparable
only to few others number three charlie
weasley
charlie was the second eldest weasley
child after bill
he was born in 1972 and though we don't
see
or hear of charlie much there are a few
things that we know about him
one of the most important aspects of
charlie's character was that he was a
great lover of magical creatures
sharing a passion with hagrid charlie
attended hogwarts during the same year
as nymphadora tonks
and after graduating he moved to romania
to pursue a career
as a dragonologist a type of
magizoologist
think news commander that specializes in
the study of dragons
the practice of dragonology is a highly
dangerous one as dragons are considered
to be
some of the most powerful creatures in
the wizarding world and the fact that
charlie worked
so closely with them is surely a
testament to his magical ability
and talents charlie was an invaluable
asset during the battle of hogwarts
and witnessed harry defeating voldemort
first hand marking the end of an era
and a resolution to the second wizarding
war number 2
bill weasley bill weasley was the eldest
weasley child
born as early as 1970 he attended
hogwarts between 1982
and 1989 and during this time he became
both a prefect
and a head boy bill is considered by
many to be the most powerful of the
weasley children
largely due to his occupation as a curse
breaker
one who removes counters or breaks
curses placed on objects
the profession is thought to be
extremely challenging and particularly
dangerous
requiring a complex understanding of
magic and a proven ability to perform a
broad spectrum of different spells
not only did curse breaking involve the
danger of cursed objects
it also presented the risk of
encountering dark witches
wizards and creatures bill was highly
skilled in arithmancy
duelling transfiguration conjuration
charms
spell creation divination and even the
dark arts
bill was truly a powerful wizard number
one
molly weasley last but certainly not
least we have
molly weasley i think an argument could
be made for having bill here but molly's
achievements are just not something that
we can ignore
in addition to raising a plethora of
talented young witches and wizards
molly's other most significant
achievement was besting powerful witch
bellatrix the strange one of the most
powerful witches in the entire wizarding
world
and one of lord voldemort's most loyal
followers
molly's curse soared beneath bellatrix's
outstretched arm and hit her squarely in
the chest
directly over her heart bellatrix's
gloating smile froze
her eyes began to bulge for the tiny
space of time
she knew what had happened and then she
toppled and the watching crowd roared
and voldemort screamed the above
statement speaks for itself
molly was powerful even if she wasn't
always depicted that way
she was primarily portrayed as an
unassuming motherly figure
known for her caring and nurturing
manner however
during the battle of hogwarts molly
proved that in times of adversity
she's able to tap into levels of power
that will give even the most powerful
witches and wizards a run for their
money
she was skilled in jewelling charms
healing magic potions
transfiguration and even the dark arts
and that concludes the list
what do you guys think do you agree with
my list
disagree with it how would you rank the
weasleys
leave a comment down below with your own
list until next time
remember anything's possible if you've
got enough nerve